I'm on the council long term investing
and the issues that we'll be working on
is what are the requirements for
institutional investors to be truly
long-term and we said looked at two sets
of issues one is the regulatory
environment that the investors operated
and the other set of issues relates to
the governance structure of these
institutional investors and what we find
is that in married very many cases
institutional investors have a governor
system which is not really well matched
with their investment strategies so the
investment strategies are long-term per
se but the governance structure the
government system of the investor is not
resilient enough to to handle the
short-term volatility that may come from
a long term investing strategy so a
long-term investor can try to to exploit
the comparative advantages by accepting
shorter term volatility but then you
have to make sure that the governance
system is robust enough to handle that
sort of volatility so what we're looking
at is what sort of metrics do we need to
measure the long term returns and what
sort of requirements for a good
governance system do we need to have in
order to make long-term investors truly
long term